President Trump in Texas today for a
first-hand look at what he calls a
humanitarian and security crisis at our
southern border two days after a major
oval office address and day 20 into the
government shutdown which remains at a
stalemate before he left the president
vowed not to cave on his desired border
wall with Mexico and said he has the
absolute right to declare a national
emergency if he can't reach a deal with
the Democrats I haven't done it yet I
may do it if this doesn't work out
probably I will do it I would almost say
definitely if we declare a national
emergency we have a tremendous amount of
fun
tremendous and while on the ground in
McAllen Texas the president doubled down
on his claim that Mexico will be paying
for the wall when I say Mexico's gonna
pay for the wall do you think they're
gonna write a check for 20 billion or 10
billion or five billion or two cents no
they're paying for the wall in a great
trade deal billions and billions of
dollars a year will be made now as
opposed to NAFTA which was a disaster
Trump then let a Border Patrol agent
explain the need for a wall just
yesterday we apprehended 133 people from
countries other than Central America and
Mexico that includes individuals from
India Pakistan China Romania Ecuador
Nicaragua on and on and on and so I know
we keep talking about the family units
and unaccompanied children and that
makes up about typically about 60 70 %
we've seen a change over the last couple
of weeks where that number is less than
50% of the apprehensions we make here in
South Texas we have 55 miles of fencing
in the sector we started a job in 2006
we need to finish that job we've got the
personnel we need the technology we need
the resources we need the infrastructure
in order to you know in order to control
this border and manage it all right
we're gonna take it around the table
quick let me start with Border Patrol
agents that's what you've been
recommending this like let the Border
Patrol agents speak for the need because
they know what is going on down well
it's not just the agents it's also
engineers because we here we need
this kind of conversation requires a lot
of nuance unfortunately when you inject
politics into anything the first thing
that disappears is nuance and compromise
it's an politics is the carbon monoxide
of thinking it's odorless its colorless
and when it enters the room all ideas
die and so what they do is so nuanced a
compromise this drives me crazy is
replaced with the prison of two ideas so
even though Chuck agrees with Donald
Trump and has agreed with him he has to
go to his respected prison he has to go
to that other prison cell and he can't
come out even though he agrees with
Donald Trump so everybody has to choose
their side and they have to live in
their own prisons and every day this
goes on it creates more and more
libertarians or people who are so
disgusted by politics they're forced to
talk to their family instead which is
good but by the way the real winner at
this border visit Ted Cruz's beard you
went from Ted Cruz that cruise missile I
mean I look at that I go I'm not messing
with that guy he should if he had grown
that beard in 2015 he might be president
or vice president would not be lying Ted
no I've tried I think I grow beard
except it stops around the chin and it
looks like you have hair here but not on
your yeah I have like mutton chops is
that what they're called mutton chops
and then I get food in it which is great
this is like two weeks I haven't shaved
want any beard for you yeah I can grow a
beard I had a beard over vacation but I
must say I was worried about you know
those terrorists crossing the border
when I saw that guy standing behind the
president and I realized it was Ted Cruz
trying to make up for not a border wall
but they absence of a chin no I'm saying
you just like you so what do you say
cruise missile yeah let me ask you Jesse
about this today
there was an article this morning that a
couple of the Democratic freshmen who
just won the Democrats who beat
Republicans right in the close races but
they beat them fair and square now
they're starting to say we're actually
for border security and this is not
necessarily good that we are going to be
in a position of not being able to build
any coalition's or get anything done if
this is our first attempt out of the
gate do you think that there are cracks
in the Democratic opposition to getting
President Trump this money for the wall
I think the cracks are coming from the
folks are burning up the phone lines
that's what politicians respond to is
letters and phone calls if you start
calling and and and clogging up the
phone lines they think that their
constituents are angry and they want
border security and they will respond
that's the best part of democracy just
pick up the phone and tell these guys
what to do they work for the people not
the other way around so you could see
that needle moving a little bit and I
honestly think this is the first time
Trump has used the traditional
presidential squeeze play on an issue
you do the oval office address you do
the little photo-op with the white hat
do the social media you ask people to
call their congressmen you maybe have a
couple rallies or something like that
take a trip to the boy to take a trip
and then you threaten something and and
right now it could be working what the
Democrats are trying to do though is
they're trying to prolong this so the
paychecks aren't paid one week and that
inflicts a new pain into the
conversation and that may affect the
dynamic a little bit so if they can time
the paycheck miss a couple more weeks
even time it with the mullah we know
what I think that you imagine that
double whammy right there yeah I still
think that you said he was wrapping up
what who's wrap Moeller well but here's
the thing I'm gonna run a theater this
is my theory I don't have any no one has
told me this but I think that the
president Jedidiah tomorrow is going to
usurp the Democrats that he will declare
this national emergency and be and be
able to say I ended the shutdown because
the Democrats wouldn't do it I have the
authority to do this national emergency
there's controversy around that but that
he'll be able to say I'm ending a
shutdown
I've obviously proved the need for this
border fence then he'll get credit for
ending the shutdown but then you'll have
everyone coming after him for
oh you acted unilaterally you don't care
about Congress you know you didn't do
this the right way so I mean I think I
think that would be I really think it
would be a mistake for him to declare a
national emergency even though I do
think he has the authority to do it in
this case I think it would be a
political don't you think he's like
marching his way up to yeah oh
absolutely because he keeps saying now
oh yes you know I I'm within my right to
do it and if Democrats don't help I'm
gonna have to do it but to answer a
question before - I think that a lot of
Democrats are coming forward and saying
to people other Democrats this is
one-tenth of one percent of the budget
we're talking about here do you really
want to be on record as not wanting to
give a 5.6 billion dollars for the
border when we're asking for 27 billion
dollars in foreign aid I mean this is
not this is not a good position to be
and this is the fraction and these are
the very Democrats who have been on
record as we've said in the past that's
coming forth in favor of border security
when you look at the polling around the
country people care about this issue
they want the border secure they may not
want the wall because that wall has been
tied with President Trump and now they
associate that with him but they want
border security so I think Democrats
have to be really careful about this and
and frankly if they are held responsible
for the shutdown I think that's gonna be
a big let's see I think that one but
Democrats are not being held responsible
for the polls are clear that's all so in
fact in the David Drucker in the
Washington Examiner they said it looks
to him like the Republicans have taken
themselves hostage and they're trying to
do things like oh you know what you can
get your tax refunds food stamps won't
be delayed for people they're trying to
ameliorate the damage that comes from
what is now I think a 20 day shutdown
second longest in history and the
difficulty for Republicans especially
Republicans in states like Colorado Cory
Gardner or even at least from Makowski
up in Alaska states either with Hispanic
population significant or a lot of
federal workers is that they feel that
this is going to hurt them with voters
so they're starting to hear from their
constituents
hey this isn't such a great deal and to
go to what Jedidiah was talking about I
think the news of today was that he
didn't declare the national emergency
and I think that part of that is that
maybe I shouldn't say Republicans I
should say conservatives remember how
strongly conservatives criticize
presidents in the past for acting as in
a tart tyrannical or despotic way and
just saying I'm going around Congress
never once in American history as an
emergency been declared when the
president could not get funding for an
issue through the Congress of the United
States and went around the Congress that
is not in keeping with our Constitution
I think a lot of conservatives have real
problems with it I thought the news of
the day was that there were people from
a hundred and forty different countries
or 40 different countries besides
Central America that we're trying to
cross the border that they apprehended
it's like a United Nations migration
into the United States of America and
the Border Patrol said Pakistan India
Romania people from Romania Wong they're
coming - you can't call the president
races not he's trying to stop Romanians
let me tell you something check the
airports if you really want to see
people from all over which is the
primary source of illegal immigration
let's actually have a conversation one
last thing so we're harmful if there's
no harmful effect no no terribly no no
cross the southern California women get
sexually assault that's reassembly
here's the real issue right now
politico's reporting that Republicans in
the Senate went to the president said
let's make a deal of reopen the
government and then - let's talk about
upgrading border security that's the
Democrats were said okay but the
president said no you're never gonna get
the border security though you'll get
the world anyway if the wall any Ronald
Reagan mistakes do you have to make when
you go to Democrats and you say you know
what we'll do this okay you cave and
then you never get your individual
Democrats here about that's so much more
sure to get to so I got a tease we're
gonna say so just sounded like something
else I don't know